تزايدت التساؤلات حول قوه الردع الروسيه
الشامله او الثالوث النووي روسي وهل سيتم
استخدامه كخيار اخير من طرف الجيش الروسي
لتحقيق مكاسف في اوكرانيا الثالوث النوويه
الروسي يعتبر اهم قوه استراتيجيه تشمل
الصواريخ البعيده بعيده المدى وعاليه
الدقه والتي تحمل رؤوسا نوويه مهامتها
الرئيسيه تتمحور حول الردع استراتيجي
الشامل في البر والبحر والجوف بالنسبه
للبرد تضم والقوات النوويه البريه من
الصاد ثابته الى جانب صواريخ يارس سوفيتيه
الصنع وصواريخ صار معك عامله بالوقود
السائل يمكنها الدوران حول الارض عده مرات
نجد ايضا في الثالوث النووي قوات نوويه
جويه او قوه نوويه
تضم طائرات استراتيجيه حامله للصواريخ
النوويه من نوع كنجال الفرد الصوتيه والتي
تزيد سرعتها 10 اضعاف سرعه الصوت ومداها
ثلاثه الاف كيلو متر وتضم قوه نوويه بحريه
تتالف من صواريخ متعدده ابرزها صاروخ
كاليبر المجنح والذي يمكن تزويده برؤوس
نوويه بالاضافه الى العديد من الغواصات
المتطوره
فاهميه الثالوث النووي تكمن في الحفاظ على
معادلات الردع في العالم خصوصا وان حصه
الاسلحه الحديثه فيه وصلت الى درجه كبيره
وفقا التصريحات الاخيره للرئيس الروسي حيث
ان عدد صواريخ المجنحه في الجيش الروسي
تضاعف 30 مره ليسجل قفصه كبيره في مجال
تزويد القوات المسلحه باسلحه دقيقه بعيده
المدى منذ بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]